after starting this company in 2012 i
was wondering
a lot of people would do marketplaces a
lot of people uh
say hey listen you got to have the fees
baked in like uber did
or airbnb another group of people say
hey don't worry about that just get
to critical mass and then later on turn
on the transactions
transaction fees and then take your
vague uh your take rate
how do you how did you do it with zumper
and what's your philosophy on this
so it was a great question we were
strongly the latter so if you think
about apartment rentals
um if you don't feel like you see
everything as a consumer you're gonna
bounce
like you're gonna spend a third of your
income on this transaction if you go to
a website that has
20 of the listings you're going to look
and you're going to know it immediately
and so supply side liquidity is
absolutely king in our industry
kleiner did our series a in 2014 so five
years ago we did our series a
and we had no traffic we had 30 000
users a month
but we had accumulated basically every
single listing in san francisco in new
york then we have more listings than
anyone else
and we did our series a entirely on that
premise jason the
supply side liquidity is king don't ever
create a barrier to it in the early days
give it away for free
build tools for those supply side
listing landlords
to manage their business on zampa even
before zumba had a single mau
and then over time uh starch an inch
into the monetization so we're strongly
the latter and i really believe that
marketplaces get to liquidity first
typically
how did you get the information that was
on craigslist
you know large part onto your platform
is it legal to just
copy it or do they try to stop you
or did you have people in manila or
india
just scraping the web and trying to
normalize data and contacting people how
did you get those first 10 000 listings
or whatever it was yeah so just as we
were launching craigslist we're going
after a bunch of competitors in our
space so we didn't touch craigslist we
had to do it like the hard way
we knew even if you crawled craigslist
which we didn't we knew that one day
you'd have to build bottom up your own
business
so we kind of cut the middle man and
just went to building it bottom up
the biggest hack we had was building
landlord tools so ways for analysts to
like create a listing on their phone
syndicate it to all the main sites and
then bring the leads back and what did
you call that tool the zumper pro
zamper pro and it was the single most
successful products we built in the
first two years even though no consumers
know about it
yeah so this is the uh phrase i don't
know who came up with it which is come
for the tool stay for the marketplace
that's it
so you heard that at that time i wish
i'd heard that i think we just made it
up as we went right we basically
just uh understood that we needed a
reason for landlords to have listings on
our platform even though we had no me
used to show them and so we used to
syndicate to zillow
to trulia to pads all these platforms
that could bring all the demand
until the day where we got big enough
and then you're like
deprecated the tool or a tool exists we
just didn't need to syndicate it out so
right now zombie landlords can get onto
zampa
padmappa this company we acquired and
also facebook marketplace where we power
a decent chunk of facebook marketplaces
rental vertical